welcome back we all know James Comey
loves the spotlight now the former FBI
director is going Hollywood Jeff Daniels
is set to play him in a four hour CBS
miniseries based on Combes book a higher
loyalty President Trump will be
portrayed by Brendan Gleeson so you know
one just what I need is more Comey in my
life
you excited what is this something you
would tune into sure I check it out I
mean I like politics I mean you know I
you know
veep and all those kind of political
shows I looked at you see because half
the time you think yeah I'm not sure
they really get it right I want to see
where they get it right when they get it
wrong how difficult is it to dramatize
the reality of American politics and
there's a lot of drama but I will say I
think Jeff James is a great actor I just
saw him in To Kill a Mockingbird on
Broadway he did a wonderful job
as for Comey I don't know you know
Democrats have maybe had more problems
with Comey than Republicans because I
think he caused Hillary the election but
you know I think people are just curious
and this you know the thing about the
Donald Trump era is it's so entertaining
Jedidiah in some ways and it lends
itself to Hollywood and so here's gonna
be a Hollywood presentation he's just
such an insufferable figure though Jesse
I mean call me I feel like people on
both sides of the aisle are just like
really I've had enough just step away
that's not gonna rate the real stuff
that rates is we're watching it right
now unfold in reality that's the good
stuff you can't over dramatize what's
happening I mean it doesn't get any
better than this of course Trump was
gonna get impeached of course it's gonna
give us everything just wait on the
second term it is appropriate that the
guy that played dumb and Dumberer
is going to be playing James Comey but
Hollywood has to white knight this guy
they have to memorialize him as the hero
in order to lock into the American
psyche that this guy was the right man
to take out a dastardly president but
once the Durham report comes out they
might have to rewrite the thing yeah I
mean till ones point though day now
Democrats had a lot of issues with Comey
as well I think if you asked them who
well I think that any candidate that
loses needs to take that on the
responsibility for themselves they lost
it nobody else can lose that for you but
if they were to say that if there was
one person that caused them a lot of
anxiety a lot of problems it was James
Comey so they they really can't stand up
I think it's pretty interesting a
premiere date hasn't been set let's be
honest
this will happen two weeks before the
election of 2020 we know when that will
happen also I'll be very interested to
see who the contributing producers are
who are the people in the current drama
outside of it that all are going to get
paid to consult for this production
who's the owner who it's gonna be
who is the actual audience the people
that actually make it you know it's it's
basic it's kind of like when people you
wouldn't guys used to write for GQ they
were writing for the guys at Esquire you
know they're all like they're all trying
to impress the Washington person oh yeah
they're always try to impress the piers
look I think they're making a huge
mistake they need to make they need to
focus on him taking down that vicious
criminal Martha Stewart that really is
the moat the high point of his heroic
career is to getting that vicious
criminal off the street Martha Stewart
and putting it or putting her in jail
but to once-once point it's true it's
like these things you have no idea what
they get wrong or get right unless until
it's about you and you know being at Fox
and seeing all these things come out
it's interesting to see how much is
wrong and how much is right and it's I
would say it's probably like 60% wrong
and 40% right there's somebody playing
me by the way Dana I don't know his name
dark and handsome I think but I think he
he doesn't even have a speaking role but
he plays me yeah he's looking at the
back runner maybe I'm just like maybe
it's just a PR photo of me on a wall
played by somebody that was the guy that
played Rudy Rudy in what not Rudy Julie
yeah I don't I can't think of his game
yeah I know what you're talking about
that should be me who is it yes Sean
should play gutfeld yeah I was thinking
more about Gilbert Godfried see that or
the guy from the progressive commercial
the insurance commercial happens why not
you pick someone heroic we once we want
you to present have to be the right
height light right I was kidding I'm
saying to Tom Cruise but he's homely Oh
and that's exactly he's 10 years older
than me is this